HONG KONG ON THE SITUATION
ACROSS INDIA.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
THE UK'S HEALTH SECRETARY SAYS
HIGHER VACCINATION RATES ARE
NEEDED FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO BE
MORE CONFIDENT IN ALLOWING
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL.
A 4 MONTH LONG TRAVEL BAN WAS
LIFTED JUST DAYS AGO TO-LIMITED
DESTINATIONS, ALONG WITH SELECT
AREAS ROLLING BACK COVID
RESTRICTIONS.
BRITISH SCIENTISTS SAY THEY
SHOULD KNOW NEXT WEEK HOW MUCH
OF A THREAT THE COVID VARIANT
FIRST DETECTED IN INDIA POSES.
IT IS EXPECTED TO SOON BE THE
DOMINANT STRAIN IN THE UK,
CNN'S SCOTT MCLAIN JOINS ME NOW
LIVE FROM LONDON.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, SCOTT.
THE INDIAN VARIANT IS SLOWING A
RETURN TO NORMAL LIFE.
WHAT DO SCIENTISTS KNOW, WHAT
DOES THE GOVERNMENT DOING TO
PROTECT PEOPLE?
>> >> THE GOVERNMENT SAYS IT'S
ANALYZING THE DATA RIGHT NOW
AND SHOULD KNOW BY THIS TIME
NEXT WEEK HOW MUCH
TRANSMISSIBLE THIS VARIANT IS
THAN THE CURRENT DOMINANT
VARIANT.
THE HIGHER THE NUMBER THE MORE
LIKELY IT IS TO DERAIL THE
GOVERNMENT'S PLAN TO FULLY LIFT
CORONAVIRUS RESTRICTIONS A
MONTH FROM TOMORROW.
THIS VARIANT IS CIRCULATING
FASTER THAN ANY OTHER IN THE UK
RIGHT NOW.
THE NUMBER OF CONFIRMED CASES
HAS DOUBLED, MORE THAN DOUBLE,
THEN THE PAST 3 WEEKS.
REMEMBER THIS IS A COUNTRY
WHERE MORE THAN 70% OF THE
ADULT POPULATION HAS GOTTEN AT
LEAST ONE DOSE OF THE VACCINE.
WE ASKED THE MAN IN CHARGE OF
BRITAIN'S LARGEST COVID-19
GENETIC SEQUENCING TO TELL US
WHAT MAKES THIS VARIANT SO
DIFFERENT AND SO DIFFERENCE?
>> ON THE BANKS OF THE GANGES
RIVER, BODIES WASHED UP DAILY.
VICTIMS, AUTHORITIES BELIEVE,
OF COVID-19.
WE OVERWHELMED HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM UNABLE TO CARE FOR THEM,
AND THE PACT CREMATORIUMS
UNABLE TO GET THEIR BODIES WHEN
THEY DIE.
AND HIS NEWFOUND MISERY IS
THANKS IN PART TO A FASTER
SPREADING COVID VARIANT THAT'S
QUICKLY MAKING ITS WAY AROUND
THE WORLD.
LEADING TO LINEUPS OF PEOPLE
HOPING TO GET VACCINATED IN THE
UK, WHERE IT'S FAST BECOMING
THE DOMINANT STRAIN.
>> SEEMS LIKE THE UK'S PATH TO
NORMALITY IS IN JEOPARDY?
>> I THINK WE DO HAVE TO LOOK
VERY CAREFULLY AT WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> DOCTOR JEFF BARRETT RUNS THE
INDUSTRIAL SCALE QUARANTINE
GENETIC SEQUENCING AT THE
BRITISH SAYING IT'S A DETAILED
SWATH OF FAST SPREADING UK
VARIANT, BUT COULD NOT PREVENT
THE MASSIVE SPIKE IN CASES THAT
FOLLOWED.
>> ARE YOU SENSING A BIT OF
DÉJÀ VU HERE?
>> YES.
I HAVE TO ADMIT, I DIDN'T THINK
I WAS GOING TO SEE THESE KINDS
OF CURVES HAPPEN AGAIN.
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T THAT MUCH
GENOMES EQUALING IN INDIA, WE
HAVEN'T BEEN CAREFULLY WATCHING
THIS FIGHT IN THE SAME WAY.
THAT MEANS WE'RE PLAYING
CATCH-UP NOW.
>> THERE IS 26 TO GENETIC
MUTATIONS WHICH MAKE THIS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE ORIGINAL
VIRUS.
MOST ARE PRETTY BENIGN, BUT
THERE ARE 5 DOCTOR BAIRD SAYS
THAT COULD HELP THE VIRUS
SPREAD EASILY.
THIS IS FOUND IN THE UK VARIANT,
THIS CHAIR TO THE CALIFORNIA
VARIANT.
IT HELPS THE VIRUS BINDS MORE
EASILY WITH HUMAN CELLS.
THERE ARE 2 SUSPICIOUS
DELETIONS OF DNA PARTS, WHICH
MAY CHANGE THE SHAPE OF THE
VIRUS.
THEN THERE ARE THESE 2, WHICH
DOCTOR BARRETT SAYS SCIENTISTS
HONESTLY DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH
ABOUT.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT ANY
OF THESE CHANGES MAKE THE VIRUS
MORE DEADLY, BUT THERE IS
CONCERN THAT SOME, ESPECIALLY
THIS ONE, MAY REDUCE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF VACCINES.
>> I THINK, AT WORST, IT WILL
BE SLIGHTLY LAST NEUTRALIZED BY
THE VACCINES.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE AT ALL
THAT FUNDAMENTALLY ESCAPE WHAT
THE VACCINES WILL BE NOT
EFFECTIVE AT ALL.
>> SOUNDS REASSURING.
IT WON'T HELP THOSE WHO HAVEN'T
GOT THE VACCINE AT ALL.
THE BRITISH HEALTH SECRETARY
SAYS ONE COMMUNITY, MOST PEOPLE
HOSPITALIZED WITH THE NEW
VARIANT DECLINED TO GET THE
SHOT WHEN THEY WERE OFFERED IT.
>> IT UNDERLINES AGAIN THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING THE JAB.
>> DESPITE INFECTIONS OF THE
NEW VARIANT, DOUBLING IN JUST
ONE WEEK, RESTRICTIONS ON
INDOOR GATHERINGS WERE EASED ON
MONDAY.
NOW, THE BRITISH PRIME MINISTER
IS WARNING THE FINAL STEP
TOWARDS NORMALITY MAY HAVE TO
BE DELAYED, DEPENDING ON
EXACTLY HOW TRANSMISSIBLE THIS
VARIANT TURNS OUT TO BE.
>> IF IT'S AT THE HIGHER, AND
WE WILL CERTAINLY HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT EXTRA MEASURES WE
NEED TO TAKE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC.
SO CRITICS OF THE PRIME
MINISTER SAYS THAT THOSE EXTRA
MEASURES TO BE TAKEN LAST MONTH
WHERE THE TOUGHEST RESTRICTIONS
WERE PLACED ON TRAVELERS COMING
FROM PAKISTAN IN BANGLADESH, IT
IS ONLY 2 MONTHS LATER THAN
INDIA RECEIVE THE SAME
TREATMENT.
IT IS ALSO ROSEMARY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE DATA AT
THIS TIME DOESN'T LOOK GOOD.